MICHAEL COLEMAN: Hi, I'm Mike
Coleman, a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud.
In this video, I
want to introduce
you to Migrate for Anthos.
Migrate for Anthos
is a set of tools
that inspects existing workloads
running in virtual machines
and automatically creates
the needed container
artifacts for modernization.
Let me break down that last
sentence into two parts
and talk separately about where
these virtual machines might
be running and what types of
artifacts Migrate for Anthos
creates.
Migrate for Anthos can
migrate both Windows and Linux
applications.
Windows applications can be
running on a Google Compute
Engine VM.
In addition to Google
Compute Engine,
Linux applications can
also be hosted on-prem
with VMware vSphere,
AWS EC2, and Azure VMs.
In Migrate for Anthos, where
your VM currently resides
is called the migration source.
For this video, the source
will be an application running
in a VM on Compute Engine.
The output from
Migrate for Anthos
is a comprehensive
set of artifacts
that you can use to
deploy your newly
containerised application.
These artifacts include
a Kubernetes YAML
file that you can use
to create Kubernetes
deployments and services,
a Dockerfile that
can be used to create
a new container image,
and other YAML
files that describe
what was actually migrated.
Once you have these
artifacts, you
can deploy the containerised
version of your application
to an Anthos cluster or to
the various flavors of Google
Kubernetes Engine,
including GKE running
on Google Cloud,
on-prem, or on AWS.
So you have an application
running on a supported source.
And you can use
Migrate for Anthos
to get it running
in a container.
But why would you do that?
There are several key benefits
to migrating your workloads.
The first is density.
Containers are much
lighter weight than VMs,
since they don't contain
the operating system,
and therefore, require
considerably fewer compute
and memory resources.
This in turn allows
greater density
of workloads across your
clusters, fine-grained resource
allocations and overall
lower infrastructure costs.
Another benefit is security.
GKE offers automatic
operating system upgrades,
freeing you from the burden
of maintaining your operating
system.
You can also augment legacy
apps with modern services.
GKE allows you to leverage
platform add-on services
to [? seemingly ?] integrate
up-to-date functionality
with existing apps.
For instance, you can
take advantage of Istio
on GKE or ASM on Anthos to
automate network and security
policies, without changing
your application code.
Additionally, you can
leverage Cloud Logging
and Cloud Monitoring
with your applications.
Unified policy and integrated
resource management.
GKE allows you to focus on
managing applications, not
infrastructure.
It offers the power of
declarative desired state
management with powerful
tagging strategies and selector
policies.
You can also move to modern
image-based management
and orchestration.
Migrate for Anthos offers
a unique capability
to extract an application
from the VM workload
and construct a Docker
image and related artifacts,
which in turn, allows you
to modernize the application
lifecycle and
operations management.
This could include integrating
with a CI/CD pipeline,
using tools like Cloud Build
to implement day 2 maintenance
procedures.
Furthermore,
image-based management
enables customers to
use GKE to perform
rolling updates, dynamic
scaling, self-healing,
and more.
So now you have a general idea
of what Migrate for Anthos
does and why you might
choose to use it,
let's jump into an
actual migration.
Migrate for Anthos has
three primary components--
the Discovery tool,
which assesses
how successful a migration of
a given application might be;
the Processing Cluster,
a Kubernetes cluster
that is used to
examine the source VM
and create the migration
plan, as well as execute
the actual migration; and
migctl, a command line tool,
like kubctl, for interacting
with the processing cluster.
Migctl is already
installed in Cloud Shell.
A migration generally consists
of the following steps.
And don't worry if you're
not sure of what each
of these steps actually means.
We're going to get
into that as we
move through this video series.
First, you need to
create a Google project,
set up service accounts,
and enable appropriate APIs.
Next, you create a migration
processing cluster.
Then you go into the process
of choosing and qualifying
your targeted workload.
Once you've done that, you can
define your migration source,
using migctl to create
a migration plan.
Then you adjust that
migration plan to ensure
that it meets your needs.
Then you create the
deployment artifacts.
And then you can deploy
your newly containerised
application.
In the rest of this
video, I'm going
to talk about the
first two steps,
since they are largely the
same whether you are deploying
Linux or Windows applications.
I will cover the remaining
steps in subsequent videos.
Now that we have the
migration process laid out,
let's jump into setting up the
prerequisites for a migration.
Migrate for Anthos requires
two service accounts.
The first service account is
used by Migrate for Anthos
to access Container
Registry and Cloud Storage.
You will use this
service account
when you install the Migrate
for Anthos components.
And it requires storage
admin permissions.
The second service account
enables Compute Engine
as a migration source and
it requires Computer Viewer
and Computer
Storage admin roles.
I will actually create
this service account
in a follow-on
video, but I wanted
to make sure you
were aware of it.
In addition to the
two service accounts,
you will enable
the following APIs
that are shown on the screen.
The next prerequisite
we need to deal with
is the Processing Cluster.
As mentioned before,
Processing Cluster
is a GKE cluster
running the actual code
that analyzes the source VM
and creates the deployment
artifacts.
So I will create a one-node
cluster here in the console.
The cluster itself is a
pretty standard cluster.
We're going to name
it Processing Cluster.
We're going to put
it in US-WEST2,
which is the same location as
my VM that I'm going to migrate.
Under the default
pool, we're going
to change that to one-node.
We only need a single node.
And then for the actual nodes,
just a couple of things.
Ubuntu image type and the N1
standard for machine type.
So with those configurations,
we're ready to click Create.
And that will go off and
that will build our cluster.
Now this is going to
take a couple of minutes.
So we'll fast forward the
video and we'll check back
in when that's finished.
OK, it looks like the processing
cluster is ready to go.
So the next step is
to actually install
the Migrate for
Anthos components.
So we'll come up here.
We'll click into Anthos,
Migrate To Containers.
We'll come up here.
And we're going to add
a processing cluster.
So click Add Processing Cluster.
And we're going to come
down to Linux workloads.
And we're going to select that
processing cluster we just
created.
Click Next.
Then we're going to run a series
of commands in Cloud Shell.
The first one is
going to be to enable
the APIs I mentioned before.
So we'll copy that,
paste that in,
and those APIs will get enabled.
The next step is to go
ahead and create the service
account that's going to allow
us access to the Container
Registry and the storage--
Cloud Storage.
So we'll paste that in and
create that service account.
Then we're going
to go in and we're
going to assign
the storage admin
role to that service account.
So we'll paste this command in.
That will create
the role binding.
Then we're going
to go in and we're
going to download the
JSON key, so that we
have that to authenticate
to the necessary services
as we go forward.
And then finally,
let's clear the screen.
It's getting a little crowded.
I'm going to go
ahead and I'm going
to start the installation
process of actually creating
the Migrate for Anthos
components on the cluster.
So using migctl, I do
a migctl setup install.
And it goes through and it adds
all the necessary components
to perform the actual migration.
This will take just a couple
of seconds to finish up.
All right.
So now I can run migctl
doctor and that'll tell me
the status of my installation.
OK, let's check again
here with migctl.
And migctl is reporting
back that the deployment
has completed successfully.
And we're now ready to perform
an actual migration, which
we're going to do in
our next two videos.
We're going to have
one on migrating
Linux applications and
the other on migrating
Windows applications.
To recap, in this
video, you learned
the benefits and
features of Migrate
for Anthos, as well as how to
configure the prerequisites.
Be sure to like and
subscribe, because we'll
be posting subsequent videos
in the series, including how
to migrate Linux and
Windows applications,
as well as best practices for
evaluating your applications
and what considerations you
need to be aware of when
planning a migration.
And to get started on
Migrate for Anthos today,
visit
cloud.google.com/migrate/anthos.